johnathan follows me on Twitter Dave do
you recommend renters insurance
absolutely the problem with not having
renter's insurance is two things one is
the things that you own inside that
rental property have no insurance on
them for theft or fire someone backs a
truck up and takes all your stuff you've
got nothing
place catches on fire
you got nothing and then there's even a
little bit of liability coverage
typically in a renters policy so if
someone trips over your coffee table and
Sue's you you have a liability policy
that would cover you somewhat on that
renters insurance in most areas of the
country around 300 bucks a year got you
a little apartment a little rental house
and that recovery about $20,000 worth of
contents inside of there which would
cover most people who are renting stuff
that's not gonna buy your brand-new
everything but it'll at least get you
something to sleep on and something to
sit on
right if something happened renter's
insurance
given that it's only 15 20 bucks a month
30 bucks a month is ridiculous to not
have so get with your insurance broker
jump on Dave Ramsey comm click on the L
P 4 P and the C property and casualty
insurance where you get your car
insurance where you get your homeowners
insurance and you can get renters
insurance there and they will shop among
several different companies and get you
the best price that's how you always
want to buy insurance is the right
broker not through a captive agent a
broker shops several companies and get
you the best deal captive agent is a
brand name that sells only their own
insurance there's no comparisons across
brands and so when you go to a State
Farm or a nationwide you just Allstate
you just get what they got that's a
captive agent when you go to a broker
they'll shop across several different
companies and
the best policy for you whatever it is
in your situation whether it's renters
or homeowners or car insurance or life
insurance or whatever insurance period
that's the way you want to buy insurance
because it's basically a shopping
service is what a broker is and they've
got your best interest at heart they're
not just trying to peddle the company's
wares and that's a big deal
renters insurance absolutely vital that
you have renters insurance I remember
years ago before I went broke I had a
whole bunch of properties that were in
the lower-income end of town and one of
the saddest things I ever saw one of our
properties caught on fire and not ain't
fault of ours and I don't remember how
the fire started but it was just a fire
I don't know whether the tenant caused
it but wasn't something that was the
landlord's fault but my stinkin house
burned down you know basically and of
course we had insurance on it as a
landlord on the house it's called fire
and II see in that situation fire and
extended coverage not homeowners but
I'll never forget going over there and
the poor people that were living there
they said well now when do we get our
check I said your check your check for
what for our might for our furniture and
our clothes I said honey you don't get a
check I can't have insurance on those I
can't legally cover your stuff I don't
have what's called an insurable interest
and the poor tenant I mean they had no
renters insurance and just broke down
crying because they had nothing we ended
up having to do like a fundraiser thing
in the neighborhood there to get them
some money to get some stuff together
and help them get started again but it
was just really sad I mean they had
nothing they didn't have a lot to start
with but they had less after that fire
so always always get renters insurance
always you'd be amazed at what a theft
will set you back or what a somebody
kicks the door and hauls off your stuff
you know
it's a big deal